non fate domande e la gente i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono pari
j
e oggi siamo su hamsik biologo che è un
bellissimo nome per un horror
sinceramente speriamo siano è una demo
quindi non so effettivamente quanto
meriti però però sono fiducioso visto il
megastore il titolo e stai calma che ne
è che è successo ma sono una tipa
arcavacata già che parte con una trama
così ha penato per te non c'è in pratica
velaria suo è uno che ha semplicemente
mi ha rapito la la protagonista credo
del gioco e ha detto se tu non mi amino
puoi amare nessun altro perfetto andiamo
ucciderlo associarmi e che non lo sapevo
c'è un piede allora non ho non so come
cosa aiuto bellissimo mi piace un sacco
è questa qua ragazzi la partenza più
bella però il nostro scherzando è fatta
veramente bene per un horror da quando
gioco l'horror in generale quindi
fantastico eccola qua gli posso sky
eccolo bellissimo posto anche uscire di
qua come lo ha definito la situazione
perfetto ragazzi non era meglio
aspettare che uscisse invece riuscire
così ad cazzo potrebbe tornare un
momento all'altro però se riesco a
trovare un'arma tipo già quella è roba
che ho preso non è male come arma pro
immagino che tu non lo utilizzerei più
ci sono dei morti va bene fa niente o
che non ci sono un miliardo di armi
posso usare per contrastarlo ma non lo
usiamo si sa mai che potrei anche
vincere contro sto stronzo dello spray
ok non mi serve a niente dei dei cani va
bene che però potrebbe anche essere
utile se uno spray al peperoncino è però
non me ne frega niente poggia lo
poggiano buongiorno non me ne frega
nulla vediamo avanti la nota lo spray ei
uomo cattivo io ho uno spray per te
posso ucciderti posso guarda traversa
pure i muri fantastico questo spray
c'era qualcosa dietro la foto dei cani
non avrei mai mai azzeccato quindi è
penso sia la porta tra l'altro di sopra
spero sia la chiave verdi sopra perché
sennò culo cioè tentati completamente a
caso let's go
teoricamente la chiave per aprire questo
posso usarla non la posso usare ma non è
per aprire questa porta troverò il modo
di capire quindi l'obiettivo è uscire da
questa porta non l'avevo mica vista ma
come va fatto non avete st porta ma è a
ma che è successo cioè vedo delle cose
rosse ma oddio ma oddio secondo me non
deve andare questi ragazzi si è bagnato
tutto oppure doveva andare così sono io
pazzo doveva andare doveva andare così
ok che cosa sto vedendo sale buongiorno
ci sono delle dita che indicano questa
madonna ma che anzi sto gioco che mi ha
fatto benissimo grazie 41 32 ok era
quella la combinazione grazie mille era
bello come sarebbe stato per lo scoprirò
nella nota di prima non li per forza
però va bene ne va la prendo grazie
gentile la gentilissimi 1
let mi dai addirittura perché non sto
capendo niente di quello che sta
succedendo all inizio pensavo fosse un
bug che non mi aveva renderizzato gli
oggetti invece no doveva andare così
cosa sta succedendo ci sono ci sono qua
siam tornati
ho fatto un giro per l'iperspazio perché
mi sembra giusto perché non dovrei farlo
4 3 1 2 almeno capito qual è la
combinazione del locker bambù l'ass
era questo ho già scritto l'impatto 4 1
3 2 sorin umida memoria di quella di uno
scimpanzé north ok va bene
41 32 le dopo c'è una s p
ma cosa me ne faccio ma io riuscire
fatevi uscire porco il demonio ma ci si
può andare qui sopra posso fuggire
credo spero vedo il fuori c'è una
griglia coccia più per forza ci può
stare e mezza in piedi è più o meno
sradica la finestra porco democratici ai
quad jetro c'è un mattone premi mattone
piemontese
comunque se lo prendo riscattino in
testa in quel che non solo che non
riesco a non prende la martello c'è un
martello e norme non lo prendiamo finora
sui pm come sa fare lì quindi tutto sto
casino per entrare qua dietro ma c'è
qualcosa qua dietro c'è un giusto
bordello per niente anche alla fine sono
stati tema sopra non c'era nulla grazie
e tanto l'ho fatto da co cacciato che
non c è bisogno di stare a cosa facciamo
è stata ovviamente in piedi però fatemi
uscire o due ore per non servire poi a
niente alla fine quindi lo è
chissà che cacchio ci devo fare questa
micro sd hobo una pala va beh non posso
prendere e che cacchio ci faccio questa
cosa ah boh mi metto a verniciata a
toccarti il ripostiglio non lo so non ho
capito di stucco ripostigli ok
no ma mi chiamano l'avevo vista ma sono
stupido ma sono stupido cioè cacciavite
per svita sto coso sono stupido come la
morte eccolo cielo nuove camicie propria
vita
oh oh oh ragazzi va bene chiudiamo no io
mi ammazzo veramente ciò non lo so ma
cosa marco cosa no va bene solo compra
giosia brian però è la ma per l'amor di
dio un attimo di tranquillità però già
avuto sosta due ore a fare una sega alla
fine per poi va dai ma dai ragazzi era
penso era accorto sto video per forza
che linea dura un minuto pensavo molto
il fatto è fatto veramente bene
l'unica roba era una demo chi ci sta per
favore meno droghe ei ragazzi spero che
vi sia piaciuto come più vi piace
iscritti anche verità non so chi e come
dovrà notiziare e noi come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]